how much would three hundred thousand
dollars change your life i am 100 about
this money i'm not gonna go home without
any money how far would you go
for a chance to win it all sam and shane
being able to pass those all throughout
the night started to worry me
they will share a pool of money to
survive
i feel like i'm getting played i love
shane shan's a threat that makes sense i
created a monster with wreck
and whatever they don't spend i feel
like i'm still gonna be the one going
home they take home
this is money game
[Music]
[Music]
last time i started thinking about a lot
of things i was up for like maybe three
or four hours
i don't know
i was starting to get kind of crazy
the light of my room was not getting any
dimmer
[Music]
i started feeling paranoid
i started thinking like even the
opportunity that i'm here and i don't
think i ever processed it
there's so many ways to play this
i came up with this whole thing i was
trying to become this new person i was
trying to evolve and shed my former
honest and cute self and trying to
become a villain
i might got a change of how i'm playing
i was thinking of all these things and i
couldn't wait for the day to begin
[Music]
[Music]
now that there is not an obvious choice
we have to figure out how to start
picking people off and even though i'm
really like hurt by it i think number
seven
kira is the obvious choice
[Music]
all right
day five everyone
there are so many endings that could pop
up there's no telling who has that for
who and how bad how'd you guys sleep
good
i still pretty good yeah i was excited
for what it was
i mean you couldn't tell me that this
would have been the group that we're at
at this point in the game so
going forward i'm expecting a lot more
surprises
well it's like watching lord of the
rings too it's like you can only get
through like maybe half of the first
movie then you're like
what oh
yes it is i say 2 46 i said 2 30. my
hyperbolic guess it seems too big to
look at right now 257. that doesn't
sound right we were at what yesterday
oh
10 000 we spent that kind of maybe those
mres and kettle i guess cover that oh we
didn't buy anything yesterday but bread
and little baby stuff so yeah we did say
about 11. yeah yeah now imagine if we
cut it back even more
we're doing that by sending people home
how did everyone learn about money no
trying to be okay trying
yeah because me i invest right oh yeah
oh that's a good thing or a bad thing
probably that's funny i mean it depends
on how you look at it like for me like i
just don't really spend a lot of money
because i don't have a lot of money to
spend so like having a credit card yeah
runner's insurance credit cards are just
up
i was at a
like a spot not too long ago where it
was just like i was in a cycle i was
just paying interest i wasn't even
paying off the debt because it was that
bad um i was considering filing for
bankruptcy and you could ask your bank
for like a like a forgiveness program
i'm on that now i'm still paying like
hundreds every month
um i haven't like fully lived in my
apartment in like three months because
i'm just like in a really kind of
situation the money is affecting
behaviors in a sense where it's like if
i can be safe
i will do whatever it takes because this
is becoming super emotional thing and
the smaller the group gets the more
emotions are going to come out and the
harder it is going to be to eliminate
people even like being here like almost
feels like more comfortable than like
being at home like i know that sounds
like overly saturated but
it
doesn't
kyra
she has a sad story
but um she's not here to win she's not a
fighter we got to
break out of the cycle of just being
okay with being broke and like oh like
this is the life how it's supposed to be
i am somebody i don't like right now
which is petty
and greedy
i want to win
i could use the money i've spent a lot
of money on this one video now on
burpees obviously how much
four grand
as soon as all of everything gets back
to normal i worry like will i be able to
survive the way i'm living right now a
lot of the times the conversation
shannon is kind of talking about herself
and what she's gonna do with the money i
can't teach
english i mean it'd be nice but it's not
a lot of money i can't keep doing this
yeah she's singularly focused like if i
was in a final two with shan i wouldn't
trust that shan wouldn't try to like
find some way to take it off you know
what i'm saying especially with what
you're saying too like you're trying to
get out
yeah like if i get any money i'm
definitely like some of it's going
towards my debt i think that wreck
is playing a smart game i'm probably not
going to be able to pay all my debt i'm
very confident that everyone is going to
vote out kira first and then rex second
i've really connected with recently and
at first i was just using him as a
shield to get voted out
but wreck is a cool dude and that one's
gonna sting a lot when it happens and
i'm fairly certain it's going to happen
i need that money to like reinvest and
make that multiply that [ __ ] and
you know win
i think that rec is definitely saying
things to make sure that he makes it to
the next day to the next day to the next
day if it's not me and you guys win the
money like take that money and
change your life
[Music]
i'm in a very peculiar situation because
obviously we have our final two
okay i get the vibe that she wants final
two with me and i get the vibe that i
could do with wreck too yeah i'm trying
to think of the best efficient way to
have a final three where like we don't
have to worry
do you know what i mean i'll only betray
here if i have to yeah so if that three
of us can win i'm good but like he can't
he doesn't need this you know and then
she does she's she's almost non-existent
yeah
i don't think i'm being played i feel
like i don't honestly almost feel like
i'm playing other people i get that
totally 100
yeah and and i do like her like not on
purpose
but i feel like it's because people
trust me and that i have been kind of in
the back the whole time personality wise
she's the person i would walk away from
at the party but in the context of this
game i'm not sending the blocker home
before i should know other people
i don't like the optics of me turning
against the only other black person here
i just don't like those optics at all
[Music]
i feel like i've made connections with
the group which like makes me really
happy
but if there's an elimination and
we end up voting ourselves like it could
get
up so easily
if the typho doesn't work i feel like
i'm still going to be the one going home
because it's between me and rick
because i i really don't think that
shane could be voted out and i don't
know if i would have the heart to vote
her out should i be nervous
[Music]
at night me and chan pass letters to
each other some of them are just talking
nonsense doing nothing but others are
actually talking game
on her end the notes to me seem to be
very worrisome when it comes to chance
so i have to try and make it seem like
me and chance
aren't as tight as
we really are
[Music]
we're the only two
that are
next to each other in a room
um and i think that everyone's starting
to see that
[Music]
i was telling sam last night i was like
bro i don't think the sleep bag is
working i folded it i still hit the
floor i was like oh dude
sam and shannon
together
being able to pass those all throughout
the night
it started to worry me last few nights
we haven't really done much actually
we like two conspiracies one game of
tic-tac-toe and then it's out
we can play during the day like all of
us we can talk each you know whatever
but at night it's just them
[Music]
at first i was looking at chance and i
was thinking he might be the person i
have to box out but then i looked at it
closely i realized that we had a lot in
common
you know we're a little older than the
rest of the group
we've
seen a lot more we've done a lot more
and i just realized like why haven't we
formed an alliance yet
i could fall asleep in this you know
yeah light that light is
terrible
but like the sun i could see from the
sun
gear is adorable when i look at her i
don't see anything i don't see limbs i
just see puppy eyes but
kira is not really a factor she's
already defeated she's not here to win
she's not here to play
[Music]
i don't think until two days ago i was
really ready to play and that's why i'm
here now i'm focused
it's game on
so rec wants to talk to chance not too
bad now that's a good name
i'm letting them talk but i'm quite very
very curious about that conversation
very very curious
i'm thinking man like anybody
that i want to send home it's probably
you
i could be completely naive but i feel
like my alliance with chance is super
super rock solid i was thinking about
how i was kind of targeting the other
day i was like i got it home wrong
it's like where the we're the oldest
you've been through the most [ __ ] rick
approached me saying that he wanted it
to be him and i in the final two if
anybody's most deserving is us you know
what i'm saying
i mean i don't deserve but like will the
others be okay
they'll be
fine dude yeah
there's an inkling of doubt
that
he changes his mind and goes with wreck
and kira so this is the first time in
the game where i feel like there is an
opportunity for me to be voted out three
bottom two i think it should be on me
okay okay well we'll talk about it more
extensively yeah yeah is not really a
factor okay yeah shannon is a threat i
love shane
that makes sense
that makes sense to me
to be honest i don't believe him i think
he just wants to make sure that he can
like you know last until he gets a
better plan beyond him just wanting you
know to make sure that he's at the end
he wants shan to go next
[Music]
hi can i order one bio bag please
thank you
yeah
now yeah
it's happening what
yeah i caught that too yeah i want them
to talk and see if chance reports back
to us
oh really yeah so that's why i'm really
curious what the conversation is
[Music]
what do we think it was it wasn't a lot
ryan's like 255. i don't remember
actually
okay halfway point and we haven't spent
50 grand yet yeah yeah that's that's
madness and i feel like we're not going
to spend more either like no we're going
to spend more but not like a 50 close to
50 grand more no money is the most
important thing to me here i've had a
rough life i'm sure the people here have
rough lives we've talked about it but i
did not come here to lose i am 100 about
this money i'm not gonna go home without
any money
bro he said frugal okay that's like
that's how much now i'll get back to you
i don't think seeing the money total on
the board is the motivator i think
seeing the amount of contestants left
over is the motivator seeing how close i
am to winning
[Applause]
sit down yeah
yeah so what i was saying
one thing that worries me is that
they're right next to him yeah me and
you were isolated yeah yeah and the only
time we could talk is like during the
day yeah yeah yeah so i was thinking i i
feel like
you need that [ __ ] i need that [ __ ]
they're gonna be fine
a couple of things that are happening
that i was kind of predicting
are happening and it's very worrisome
people who don't typically talk are now
talking which is fine because the
numbers are dwindling but it's just like
the pairing is just kind of like that
never happened yeah
do you think if it came down to like a
final two like that same one like not
like keep you or like
chances
not even that
before that
maybe for that [ __ ] that's what i'm
saying
and that's what i'm worried about
something about shane when i feel like
she's playing a different game yeah yeah
every time she says i'm like
what are you what are you playing like
what's your what's your goal yeah i feel
like i'm getting played right
i kind of trust chan but at the same
time i feel like she might have a vote
against me was it about like a specific
like
deal or like no it was just about being
black oh
and granted he like you that he used
that against you
because has he talked to me separately
ever since no that would make me agree
that's what i'm saying it's the fact
that you do something
like that
because he says things like i take up
oxygen when she's taking up oxygen i
know i have to hold my breath
you can be a good person like when
money's on the line yeah people do crazy
things i understand that i totally get
that but i'll be damned if you use
something like that
and then of course because it's him how
he fits in his life outside of you he
feels connected to him too
[ __ ]
i guess other people think she hands a
target
crazy
[Music]
i feel like if it's
me you like and kira after this
i don't think rick could convince you a
curative audience to me you couldn't so
i feel comfortable with it and i don't
think rank
could convince you to vote against me no
i think i'm probably going to want to
get him out next
but we'll see i think wreck has 100
figured the game out and has worked it
to his advantage he's a gamer and he he
needs the money like the rest of us so
he's gonna put himself in a position to
win
where's your head at man
all over the place okay so okay this is
this is the funny part after our
conversation you know i felt great and
then like then just over time like
dipped and i just think it's because
like the shift in dynamics right you
know um i was like okay this is in my
head
what's going on and it's pure ego there
are times when like we're talking and i
feel like yo i feel like shannon is like
i'm making the conversation i'm like is
it that shane is dominating the
conversation or that you're not this is
just because shannon and i are so
assembly
i'm glad you said something because
honestly man i'm not gonna lie to you
that [ __ ] hurts oh i'm sorry i'm not
gonna cry but that hurts i'm sorry i
wasn't trying to like change no i know
you weren't trying to i honestly thought
i was like just shutting down i thought
i thought i was just more like
internalizing everything and clearly i
was not but when you act like that i'm
like yo did i get jeed again like i
thought it was all internal right no one
in this building is trying to make me
feel that way i apologize if i if for
making you feel some kind of way no
matter how it got to you no matter if it
was direct i apologize for doing that at
this moment i don't trust shan according
to rec and again he could be lying she
told rec that sam told her that i wanted
her to go and sam had to convince me to
let her stay which
is not the truth at all i understand
but i'm not gonna act like i wasn't hurt
you know that's why i appreciate your
apologies i accept it i definitely
accept it absolutely i understand
[Music]
all right are you doing okay yeah i know
she told me that i guess someone had
mentioned something that i guess i said
and it like really hurt her feelings and
i have no idea what it could have been
if that's the narrative that she's
spending then i can help i wish you
could know what she's but i wish i wish
i'd know i feel like she's built up a
whole narrative in her head that that i
don't like her something that we have to
because she's playing games with her
yeah she's playing games or she's
convinced and either way i'm not safe
now it's kind of become a
self-fulfilling prophecy because now i
do want her gone but because of whatever
it was that she's built yeah
i'm just really shocked going into this
elimination now because now i feel like
okay now i need to take shane out
because now she thinks i have it out for
her so now i think she has it out for me
and that's the twisted part about this
game
[Music]
not jobs job looking for jobs
[Music]
okay elimination vote begins
maybe it's lack of sleep but i'm so sure
what's gonna happen but i'm not
it's crazy but what if everyone's
planning against me i have no idea
just this constant state of fear that i
live in in this game it's crazy
i don't like this at all
lately it's been looking a little shaky
and
i'm worried that
after a
an elimination or two that i might be
next
[Music]
it's real it's real
part of me kind of like wants to be
stupid and keep shane here just to prove
that like i didn't have anything against
her but i'm voting for her to go now
because as long as she's in this game i
don't feel safe i mean i feel like i
said
said everything that i
need to say about this i think rec is
really smart and he knew that he wasn't
having a very strong connection with
anybody and wreck is smart enough to
notice that me and shan were looking
like a pair so rec used this moment to
get chance on board with him and split
me and shan up and make us all
vulnerable and by ourselves well i
thought there was an alliance between
shan chance and sam and i said you know
what i gotta break it
i've been making plays i deserve i
deserve this money
i hope you say this
and i hope you know i'm sorry
at the end of the day i have to kind of
choose what's going to benefit myself in
this game
so
[Music]
if you have a big personality people are
gonna come after you
[Music]
there's nothing worse than looking at
the screen and and waiting for an answer
[Music]
wow
i think it was do or die
self-preservation so if anybody betrayed
me just to save themselves i could
understand it i don't know if i respect
it so much
as for the
architect and the engineer of my
elimination i'm hoping it's not chance
because that would be extremely
disappointing for me i'm upset but i get
to i have to go home because i was
worried about how i would look in the
eyes of other people
[Music]
the good news is
if i can keep kyra over wreck that i'm
good but
part of me is worried i created a
monster with wreck
i told chance that we should keep
and now wreck it looking like he's
running things
chance convinced me sam down for
splitsies i want it to be us top three
if it really came down to it we would
have to let sam go
give me a hug
yeah that was hard
uh all right yeah we move on with the
game i guess
[ __ ] yeah
i mean yeah
[Music]
all right
we made it all right guys i think it's
going i feel really tired [ __ ] up bro
yeah
three days ago wreck was on the chopping
block and now he's the man of the
hour good night guys
hope i'm making my friends and family
proud
all the viewers rooting for me i feel
more than safe i feel like um i'm
swimming in a bottle of
of johnson johnson baby tears
man
stan kind of imploded my game completely
bags me into a corner like i didn't want
to get her out
oh
god
for it to turn within five to ten
minutes like a whole group shifting
and voting shan when i thought
everyone's voting kira is wild
today was so jam-packed it's crazy
i'm down for us to all vote together and
try and win this thing together but i do
have slight doubts
that rex gonna want me out
especially after today because he
orchestrated the whole thing with shan
he's gonna keep me up all night
next time on money game if i'm being
honest i don't trust rec
anymore after him
personally targeting shan and then now
targeting kira i hope you're not mad at
me if you see this later on but kira
like
you gotta go there will be elimination
today
immunity is available to purchase for 10
of the remaining plots can we all just
like promise to not buy immunity please
i might buy immunity